ستطلق على هذه الخدمة الإخبارية اسم
شبكة الكيبل الإخبارية وستقوم ببرنامج
محدث باستمرار لمدة نصف ساعة
لأخبار الأعمال والأخبار الرياضية
والرياضية على مدار 24 ساعة وأنا أعلم
أننا سننجح وأتعهد لكم
بأننا لن نسمح للجمهور الأمريكي  down
[Music]
كما تعلم ، هذا هو اليوم الأول
لشبكة أخبار الكيبل وكنا
نعتقد أنك قد ترغب في معرفة المكان الذي
نعيش فيه وبعض منشآتنا ، لذا
إليك جولة في CNN مع Chris curl و
Dawn Farmer ، إنها أنت ومعلمها  تحكم في
أن الإشارات من كل تلك
الأطباق تصبح صورًا وأصواتًا ،
فهنا يتم تحويلها جميعًا
إلى أشخاص وإلى البرامج
التي ستشاهدها هنا على القناة الإخبارية
وأحد أكثر الأشخاص ازدحامًا هنا هو
فاتورة مدير الأقمار الصناعية لدينا  Pappa ونحن
مشغولون للغاية هنا لأن لدينا إمكانية الوصول إلى
أي إشارة يتم إرسالها عبر
قمر صناعي محلي يصل إلى 98 في أي
وقت ، لدينا 20 جهاز استقبال هنا حتى
نتمكن من ضبط ما يصل إلى 20 إشارة  في
نفس الوقت ،
سيكون لدينا إمكانية الوصول إلى أي مكان
في المنزل هنا في CNN من هنا ،
تنتقل المواد حرفيًا عبر
الغرفة مباشرةً هنا حيث
يلتقط المنتجون والكتاب الصور
والكلمات ويحاولون تجميع
القطع الفعلية التي تريدها.  انظر على الهواء على
شبكة أخبار الكيبل ، الرجل المسؤول
هنا هو تيد كافانو تيد ، آسف ،
عفواً كيف تجمعون هنا
أخبرني أننا سنقوم بسحب المنتجين هنا
كل واحد يفعل ساعتان
يظهر عرض ساعة ثم أربع ساعات  بعد ساعة أخرى ،
يظهرون أنهم يأخذون المواد من
المسبح ويرسلونها إلى
غرفة شريط الفيديو حيث يتم تنسيقها
مع الأجنحة ويتم تنسيق الشريط
ثم يتم توصيله إلى
المرساة ونتمنى لهم
التوفيق معها ، شكرًا جزيلاً  الكثير من هنا
عبر مكتب المرساة عبر
منطقة الرياضة إلى عنصر تحكم كما
نسميه وهذا ما يقف عليه كريس الآن
.
يجلس مديروك ومنتجونا هنا لتقديم نشرات الأخبار
لدينا ، وتقارير الأشرطة الخاصة بنا وجميع
خلاصات الأقمار الصناعية الخاصة بنا تأتي معًا لتكون جزءًا
من تغطيتنا الإخبارية المستمرة ،
والتكنولوجيا هنا هي الأحدث
وأفضل لوحة الصوت هذه ، على سبيل المثال ،
هي بالفعل واحدة  من النوع الذي يمكننا استخدامه
لحفل موسيقى الروك ولكننا نستخدمه فقط
للتأكد من أنه يمكنك سماع الأخبار
كما يحدث ،
تأتي جميع تقارير الأخبار الأجنبية عبر هذا المكتب
من مراسلينا ومكاتبنا في
جميع أنحاء البلاد إلى الخارج لدينا
من الأشياء التي نتحمس لها حقًا
هي قدرتنا على استخدام
تغطية الأقمار الصناعية للتغذية من غرفتنا
ومكاتبنا في لندن والتغذية من
نقاط مختلفة حيث  القصص
تندلع في العالم وتجلب
المواد هنا إلى أتلانتا
حيث سنعرضها على الهواء بأسرع ما
يمكن
أعتقد أننا سنحصل على
المزيد من الأخبار الدولية على
أعتقد أننا سنحصل عليه بشكل أسرع كثيرًا ،
ستحصل على
فرصة لرؤية المزيد من الطريقة
التي تجري بها الأمور في العالم على شبكة CNN ،
ما أحدثه الرجل الذي يقلب التوابل
معدات للتأكد من
حصولك على أحدث مقطع لقصة الطقس ،
ما هي كل هذه التكنولوجيا الجديدة ، حسنًا ،
هذا أخف شيء في
الإبلاغ عن الطقس هو الكمبيوتر
كما رأيته ، أنا متأكد من
أن هذا هو طقسنا في جميع أنحاء غرفة الأخبار بالفعل
قم بفحص الكمبيوتر وننقر على خطوط National
Weather Service
ونلتقط كل جزء من المعلومات الفردية التي تمتلكها
National Weather
Service والتي يقومون
بتوزيعها في جميع أنحاء الولايات
المتحدة ، ولن تضطر إلى تمزيق الأسلاك
بعد الآن.  الأزرار الصحيحة ،
لا نقوم بتمزيق الأسلاك على الإطلاق الآن إذا حدث ذلك
إذا كنا نسجل قائمة طويلة من
درجات الحرارة ، فمن الواضح أنه من
الصعب علينا تذكرها ، لذا بالنسبة
للنسخ الاحتياطي القديم ، يمكننا وضع هذا الشيء
في وضع مثل هذا والطباعة  الأشياء
من الجزء العلوي منها والمضي قدمًا وتمزيق
الأسلاك إذا أردنا أن تبدأ الذاكرة
بالفشل قليلاً ولكن لا تعلم جيدًا
أننا لا نخدع بالورق في جميع أنحاء
الطقس ولدينا جميع الأدوات الإلكترونية
التي  يسعدني حقًا أن أكون هنا في
بداية شيء خاص جدًا
والصحافة التلفزيونية ويسعدنا
أنك هنا معنا لمشاهدة
القناة الإخبارية مع استمرار الأخبار